[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: Hi, and welcome.
We're here at the Security
Zone at Next with Sam Lugani,
an expert in phishing
attacks at Google Cloud.
SAM LUGANI: Hi, Yufeng.
Happy to be here.
YUFENG GUO: So phishing attacks
are becoming a huge problem
today at companies, aren't they?
SAM LUGANI: Yes, they are.
Phishing attacks are a very
common type of security attack.
In fact, a study
conducted by PhishMe
showed that 91% of cyberattacks
started with a phishing email.
YUFENG GUO: Wow.
So phishing is one
of the main ways
that security attackers
will attack companies.
SAM LUGANI: Yes.
Let's walk through an example.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's say that an attacker
is targeting your company
and you're the security admin
responsible for protecting
your organization.
So the attacker
is going to start
by doing some research
on your company
on LinkedIn, where they can
make a list of employees
that they want to target.
The attacker then sends
personalized emails
to these employees trying to
get them to click on a link
or respond with
sensitive information.
YUFENG GUO: So what happens
if an employee opens
one of these emails or links?
SAM LUGANI: Well,
let's find out.
Let's say you are one
of the employees that's
being targeted with
this phishing attack
and you are going to go through
your inbox in the morning.
On the screen here, you're going
to see some emails come up,
and you have to
choose whether you
think the email is a phishing
email or a safe email.
YUFENG GUO: OK.
I think I can handle this.
SAM LUGANI: Oops.
That was a phishing email.
It's hard to notice,
but you can tell
by looking at the email
domain in the From field.
YUFENG GUO: So what
happens if I miss
a phishing email like this?
SAM LUGANI: Well, if you
respond to the attacker's email
or click on a link
in the email, you
may end up giving the attacker
access to sensitive data.
Let's try another one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well done.
You've spotted a phishing email.
How could you tell?
YUFENG GUO: Well, this URL
domain name looked suspicious.
SAM LUGANI: Right.
Good spot.
Details like this
are easy to spot
if you're looking for them.
But as you've seen, when
you're going through your inbox
and trying to work,
you don't have the time
to look at these little
details in emails.
YUFENG GUO: Right.
And I can't train
all my employees
to go through each email in
detail to spot phishing emails.
SAM LUGANI: You just got one of
two right, which isn't too bad.
But a report from Intel
Security on phishing attacks
showed that 97% of users
are not able to identify
a sophisticated phishing attack.
But luckily, if you're
a security admin,
you have a few tools
at your disposal.
The first tool is Gmail.
Gmail uses the power of a
billion plus user community
to protect against
phishing attacks.
As emails come into
your Gmail inbox,
they will automatically
be scanned
to identify phishing emails.
And if a phishing
email is detected,
it's discarded before
hitting the user's inbox.
But these emails are often very
sophisticated and difficult
to spot.
So Gmail now uses machine
learning to identify patterns
across messages.
This allows Gmail to
identify suspicious emails
that the ML engine says have
a high probability of being
a phishing email.
YUFENG GUO: Wow.
So with machine learning,
Gmail is finding patterns
in phishing emails
from billions of users
and using that ML model
to identify emails
with a high phishing
score or prediction.
SAM LUGANI: Yes, exactly.
So as attackers launch
more phishing attacks,
Gmail is learning
from those attacks
and getting smarter at
defending against them.
YUFENG GUO: So with Gmail,
most phishing attacks either
don't hit my employee
inboxes at all
or these emails are sent with a
warning if they're suspicious.
SAM LUGANI: Yes, that's right.
Gmail protects your
employees from having
to worry about scanning
each email manually
for phishing attacks.
YUFENG GUO: So is
Gmail all I need
to stop these phishing attacks?
SAM LUGANI: Gmail
is a first line
of defense and essential for
preventing phishing email
attacks.
But you also need
a way to protect
against phishing websites
and stolen passwords, which
is why Gmail works hand-in-hand
with Chrome browser
and tighten security
keys to provide end
to end phishing protection
for your company.
YUFENG GUO: Well, Sam, thank
you so much for showing us
how companies can defend against
these attacks with Google
Cloud.
SAM LUGANI: My pleasure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]